start off this hour with Nolan in Lake
Charles Louisiana
I know 'ln how are you hi thank you
taking my call
sure what's up oh this is my problem
mm a loss like $20,000 in my 401k
I got about 145,000 and I put in the
safety fun I'm getting 1% and listening
to you sound like I need to boot back in
and I just want to know how and what be
the best way to remember for one okay
that can yeah
so you moved it out at the bottom I did
she has the world's worst timing I hear
you talk about jumping off the click and
nobody hold my hand well that's what I
did yeah okay ouch
yeah that's um yeah there's otherwise
you wouldn't have lost the money you
would have made it back many times over
since then and so you've been out since
the bottom of the Dow at 60 60 300 and
now it's at 27,000 all right I read
boots like Larry Bates and David am I
saying it communes and collapse and all
that jobs real real nervous about all
this yeah okay well the safety account
you would have put it into would have if
the economy collapse would have
collapsed too so that was the misnomer I
guess um
ouch so I got 144,000 sittin on the
sidelines and also got like a hundred
and seventy thousand cash thanks how old
are you
54 okay so if we made a list of
companies that sounded like this and we
said okay Home Depot McDonald's
coca-cola Apple Exxon and we made a list
of companies that sounded like that that
you've heard of the names that are big
huge companies right we made a list of
those and we said alright as a group we
know that one or two of them will go
down and we may even completely collapse
during that time General Motors Ford I
mean we'd put all these kinds of people
in this lid
strike Alcoa aluminum whatever right and
if we said all right we know some of
those companies will go broke over the
next 20 years by the time you're in your
seventies but as a group do you believe
that that group of companies will go up
in value over the next 20 years or down
in value they should go up okay
the and I agree with that and actually
the data supports your supposition that
you know there's zero 20-year periods in
the stock market's history that didn't
make money all of them have gone up any
possible 20 consecutive years you could
pull data on have gone up in value for
that matter almost nineteen ninety eight
percent probably of the ten year periods
have gone up in value in the 90
percentile five-year periods have gone
up in value and so if you understand
that then you go well I'm buying a home
in a neighborhood that is a solid
neighborhood you know good trees it's
the good end of town so to speak right
and I asked myself if that if real
estate gets really soft and some people
on the street get foreclosed on am I
gonna panic with that house and sell it
or am I gonna stay in that house for
five or ten years because I know that's
a quote unquote good neighborhood you
know because you don't get a guarantee
on your house either right nope so
that's how I think about the stock
market I think about it when I'm buying
good mutual funds across all those big
companies long term over a long period
of time like decades then am i safe if I
ride out the storms it does come and go
it goes down and it goes up and the news
reports scary stuff every day I mean
there's something to be scared about
every single day and if you don't think
so just watch the news I mean there's
things we should all just be panicked
about at all times watch the news you
know they tell us every bad thing that
can happen out there and sometimes
stock market goes down because of some
of those things but I just count on it
over the long term I'm in a good
neighborhood and it's going up in value
the good neighborhood is a you know 9200
of America's best and brightest
companies as a group over 20 years are
going to make money and that keeps me
from panicking and jumping out when it
goes down like it did in 2008 and if you
can get there with your intellect and
with your emotions both then that tells
us you should move this money into some
good growth stock mutual funds
now the 170 you've gotten cash you may
want to buy a piece of paid-for real
estate with that you might rather own a
rental house I don't know
I like real estate I've got a bunch of
real estate and if you want to buy a
rental house with some of that hundred
and seventy in cash that'd be fine but
pay cash for it and buy it in a
neighborhood that you think is gonna go
up in value because you don't get a
guarantee and be willing to be a
landlord that's firm about collecting
your rents and fair about keeping the
house up and maintaining it and that
kind of stuff you've done a good job I
mean you got 300 grand you're not a
broke guy that's pretty impressive dude
really especially considering you kind
of sucked since 2008 at this whole game
so but yeah I mean if I'm you I'm moving
my 401k back into mutual funds that's
where mine are and I've got to spread
across growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
you know that's the whole thing yeah and
so you know that's what I would do and
that's my reason for doing it but again
I'm not I'm not making my decisions
based on the emotions of the nightly
news caster if the people on the nightly
news on NBC or fox or CNN or ABC or CBS
make your investment decisions for you
you're screwed you're never going to
make good decisions
they'll keep you scared your whole life
it's it's it's what they do it's their
their goal and they're really good at it
so now I just but yeah I think they'd
move that 401k and a mutual funds and
I'd move that 170 that direction or I
would move it into some paid for real
estate that you pay cash for folks
that's what I do personally
now there's the difference in this
financial show and maybe a few others I
don't know what other people do I only
know what I do
and I don't I do not give you advice
that I don't follow
personally I personally only have term
life insurance
I have never leased a car nor will I
have released a car I have been stupid
enough to finance a car back in my youth
and I've had a car payment in decades I
don't owe a dime of dad anywhere and I
don't have a credit card and I haven't
in decades I do the stuff we talk about
my wife Sharon has one of my daughter
Rachel's fancy envelope systems in her
purse she uses the envelope system and I
take home a check and she cashes it and
puts it in cash still to this day and
we're multimillionaires I live the stuff
that I teach my 401k is invested exactly
like we're talking about I don't have
any side secret rich people deals that I
don't that aren't good enough for the
little man if I tell you to do it it's
stuff I'm doing so if it's if it's wrong
I'm screwed to people so that's it this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]